all right coaches just make sure we've
got everybody
all right find a seat and we'll roll
all right just a little something to
remind you
why we're here right so we did a great
job last year that was last year
this is the new year i want the guys
that are here from the team from the
past which is most of you
to remember all the hard work and
dedication that you put in for that
season
nothing says that you can't run it back
that's that's what we're shooting for
right here
we're gonna do it but it starts tonight
and then dedicate yourself as we finish
up this season
likewise with all this covet stuff
dedicate yourself to that keep your
faces covered man
and let's not shut down the nfl we got
all the talent in the world right here
we want to take full advantage
of it
[Music]
fascinating look at the new reality of
the national football league peter the
face shields the face masks
and that's the way it's going to look
all year long hard knocks is going to be
unlike anything we've ever seen so
the season is going to be unlike
anything we've ever seen the draft today
the teams that actually could benefit
from this upside down topsy-turvy
unpredictable nfl season
i'll give you the first pick and off we
go
i'm going to take the denver broncos the
reason i'm taking the broncos mic is
because
uh you know you look at the covid map
right now and the covid map has hot
spots
all throughout some very hot spot
nfl regions the state of florida with
three teams
is on fire the state of texas with two
teams
on fire southern california with two
teams on fire
and so in nevada you know on fire with
the raiders there
but and and look i'm not just picking on
those they're they're everywhere
but the point i was gonna make is that
if you look at a map
of covet cases in the united states
there's
very very few colorado has done a
fantastic job
against covet i should i i'm not a
you know an epidemiologist or anything
like that but that's one of the few
places in the country
that you can travel in and out of
without having to worry about
quarantining
when you leave there so i i just say
that
i think there's an advantage to playing
for the denver broncos and knowing that
you're not going out into the world and
uh you know having to worry about so
much about
getting gas or or maybe doing a pickup
meal to go
so to me and the fact that
they have totally remade their offense
if drew lock is
any good this is going to be an
explosive team
yeah i'm surprised by your pick i
understand the reasoning and there is
something to be said for being in a
location that is currently doing well
against the virus although
the one thing that we've seen over the
past few months is it's subject to
change and one of the things i heard on
the news this morning the hot spot
moving from the sun belt up into the
midwest
as it peaks in some of the the areas
where it's been really bad lately and
maybe begins to migrate elsewhere i
i'm just gonna in any the more
uncertainty
the more chaos the more upside down
twists and turns the more i have faith
in bill belichick and new england
patriots even with six guys opting out
even with more possibly joining them
it's the ultimate do your job
next man up no excuses no woe is us
they got cam newton they're in a place
where the bars and the restaurants
for indoor seating aren't open and
likely won't be
open so that reduces the temptation
belichick will do a great job
of making the players accountable of
making the team leaders
make the young players accountable he'll
weed out the guys that he thinks could
maybe create the risk of bringing the
virus into the facility
they will not screw around they will
have a plan for everything and their
plans will have plans and their plans
plans will have plans
and it will all be buttoned up and they
will
unlike any other team i think find a way
to thrive through these rules
you know with and and look we know
someone's going to do it peter
the very liberal use of injured reserve
great opportunities to stash players
this year
because you can put anyone on injury
reserve with the ability to return after
only three weeks
whatever the rules are we know one guy
is going to figure him out immediately
and he's going to use them to their full
advantage and push
the limits that's bill belichick that's
why i feel like the patriots
are going to be fine if not better than
they would have been in a normal year
ah man i don't know who's playing for
him but
you know we might
we might be able to pick if if the if
the
patriots finish nine and seven i know
who's going to be my coach of the year
this year that's all i can say
um i i would i would go next with the
kansas city chiefs just because i think
the chiefs have more of a margin for
error
than other teams in the league do and
you know they
even though they've lost laurent
duvernay tardif they now lost damian
williams
the hundred yard rusher from the super
bowl two touchdowns
in the fourth quarter to clinch that
game that's a that's a loss
but to me i think that they were already
in such
great solid shape because of what they
didn't lose from both their coaching
staff and their team
my feeling is patrick mahomes coming
into his own
knowing and understanding
how much uh how much talent he has
on his side my way of thinking is when i
look at this team right now
i i think they're gonna have a good
solid long run at greatness mike
yeah i agree i'm not real comfortable
with the multiple players who are
predicting
six or seven championships like chris
jones or tyree kill i mean look they had
to do it the hard way last year
down double digits in every postseason
game including
24 in the first half against the texans
down 10 with seven to play in the super
bowl
so it's not easy especially as the
target on your back gets larger and
larger
but they they do have the table set they
do have the continuity even with
a couple of their starters on offense
opting out i understand what you're
saying
there and i think andy reid will be a
very strong voice in making sure that
guys are responsible and patrick mahomes
also
as the team leader unquestioned will be
holding the younger guys accountable and
he's still one of the younger guys so
the younger guys are more likely to
listen to him
than some 35 year old quarterback trying
to lecture to a 22 year old all right
uh next one for me man ah
this gets difficult and i i feel like i
need to use an
nfc team but you know we had him on
earlier
in a clip from his press conference
yesterday i got to go with mike tomlin
of the pittsburgh steelers
you know mike tomlin does not get enough
credit for his ability to hold together
a team that easily could implode at any
given moment he somehow kept antonio
brown
pointed in the right direction for a
decade and as we've learned over the
last 18 months
that is a herculean task in and of
itself that no one else is capable of
even attempting you throw in what
happened last year with ben
roethlisberger gone week two look
mike tomlin takes his guys he coaches
them up
no excuses he's going to keep that virus
out of the facility he's going to hold
his guys accountable
he's gonna make sure guys go home and
stay home
and whatever adversity comes their way
he's proven that he can
thrive in it and i think he's gonna he's
ultimately gonna shrug at this
because he will be certain that his guys
do everything that's expected of them
to keep the team healthy and keep the
team pointed in the right direction
mike i'm gonna uh stun you with this
pick because it's your team i'm gonna
pick the minnesota vikings
and it's kind of odd seeing that four
days ago
um the guy who's in charge of all of
their
uh infection control in the building
eric sugarman
tested positive for covid19
but i feel pretty confident that that
was not at the facility
be that as it may however that happened
you know there's something about being
in a place two weeks ago today
i got a tour of the vikings training
facility
and how it was set up um basically
for you know to to battle covet
and you have been in this building mike
this is like four or five warehouses
you know not just the building but the
practice fields
and all of the space that they have
to put things in and so to me
in my opinion this is going to be a team
that does well when it has to
be in different spaces because there is
so much space there and
i think the one other thing is you look
at mike zimmery's an all-time coach
but you know what mike zimmer has
approached this
with the following attitude just tell me
what to do tell me what the rules are
and that's what we're going to do and he
hasn't fought it at all
so to me i like the vikings because i
like their space
i like their attitude i like a lot of
the leaders
on this team as well because i think
they're home bodies quite honestly
and that's the key guys who will gladly
stay at home and guys who can influence
those young players on the roster to
stay at home as well
all right the next one for me and this
as sims would say embolizes the various
teams that have
low expectations that's he said that
recently
i think it was emblematic and symbolizes
he was trying to say and it kind of came
out mashed up together but hey i've done
that before
um not with that word but with others
any team with low expectations this year
but i'm picking washington specifically
because you've got an accomplished head
coach
who's been through a rebuild process in
carolina he did very well
relative to what the prior season was in
2011 with the lockout
and i i just think that when you
with everything else that's going to go
crazy all these teams that we're just
glossing over have the potential to have
it all fall together for themselves
and and and i feel like with washington
like they've been through all the crap
they've dealt with the name change
they've dealt and they're still dealing
with
the horrible allegations from 15 former
female employees of
of uh sexual harassment in the workplace
but i feel like ron rivera
is going to get these guys focused
and the and we're not going to expect
anything out of them they're in a weak
division
i just think washington and other teams
that are just like completely off the
radar that we're disregarding have a
chance
because this uncertainty is going to
potentially tighten everything up peter
so that's my pick let's review these
real quickly before we head to break
peter's got the broncos
the chiefs and the vikings i've got the
patriots the steelers in washington
and more broadly anyone with low
expectations because this is a year
where truly anyone
can pull it off if they can just stay
healthy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports